me preguntan cuál es el mínimo común
múltiplo de 20 y 2 y bueno me dicen que
otra forma de ver esto es mcm de 20 y 2
es igual a signo de interrogación de
hecho es justo lo que yo quiero saber y
bueno recuerda que el mínimo común
múltiplo de dos números tiene que ser un
múltiplo en común de ambos y además que
sea el mínimo pero fíjate que aquí yo
tengo la suerte de que el 20 es un
múltiplo de 22 por 10 es 20 por lo tanto
20 es un múltiplo de 2 y aquí puedo ver
en este primer ejercicio que el mínimo
común múltiplo de 20 y 2 va a ser 20
porque 20 es múltiplo tanto de 20 de sí
mismo como de 2 por lo tanto si yo pongo
mi respuesta 20 vamos a ver que el
resultado está bien perfecto así que
vamos a hacer el siguiente ejercicio me
dice cuál es el mínimo común múltiplo de
24 de 18 otra forma de ver esto es
el mcm de 24 y 18 es igual a signo de
interrogación ahora lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que en este caso ni 24 es
múltiplo de 18 y mucho menos 18 es
múltiplo de 24 así que es hora de sacar
el pizarrón y vamos a calcular el mínimo
común múltiplo de 24 y 18 vamos a
calcular el mínimo común
múltiplo de 24 y 18 ok ahora hay varias
formas de resolver este problema pero
para mí la que más me gusta es encontrar
la descomposición en primos de 24 y de
18 y fijarnos que el mínimo común
múltiplo debe tener todos los primos
tanto del 24 como del 18 como hacemos
eso bueno pues analicemos el 24 el 24 y
para esto voy a hacer un árbol de
factorización el 24 bueno lo primero que
se me ocurre es que tienen mitad el 24
tiene mitad y la mitad de 24 es 12 así
que voy a poner el 12 justo aquí el 12
también tiene mitad así que la mitad de
12 ese es y entonces voy a poner el 6
justo aquí ahora en 6 también tiene
mitad la mitad de 6 es 2 y por lo tanto
voy a poner aquí tercera o 3 y 3 ya es
un número primo por lo tanto estoy
diciendo y eso lo voy a apuntar aquí es
muy importante que 24 es
exactamente lo mismo que dos por dos por
dos por tres que recuerda que también
hay otra forma de verlo esto es lo mismo
que dos elevado a la 123 elevado al cubo
por 3 pero bueno realmente de aquí es
donde voy a utilizar toda esta
información para encontrar el mínimo
común múltiplo de entre estos dos ahora
le toca el 18 así que hablemos del 18 el
18 tiene mitad así que para
descomponerlo en primos lo primero que
voy a hacer es sacar la mitad y la mitad
de 18 es 999 no tiene mitad pero tiene
tercera entonces saquemos la tercera 9 y
la tercera de 9 es 3 y 3 es un número
primo por lo tanto ya acabamos la
factorización en primos del 18 es decir
que podemos ver el 18 y déjame ponerlo
aquí el 18 es exactamente lo mismo que
dos por 3 por 3 2 por 3 por 3 o dicho de
otra manera
por 3 elevado al cuadrado ok pero
realmente de aquí voy a sacar esta
información para encontrar el mínimo
común múltiplo de ambos ahora sí cuando
yo pienso en el mínimo común múltiplo en
el mínimo común múltiplo entre estos dos
entre 24 y 18 entonces lo que se me
ocurre hacer es tomarme el primero toda
la descomposición de primos del 24 tengo
que elegir alguno de estos dos pero el
24 semanas se buena opción entonces el
24 era el mismo que 2 por 2 por dos por
tres entonces 2
por dos por tres ahora date cuenta que
con estos números con esto de aquí
formamos el 24 por lo tanto el 24 ya
está formado con estos aquí ahora vamos
a fijarnos en el 18 el 18 es dos por
tres por tres vamos a ver cuáles de
estos primos ya están aquí insertados y
cuáles de ellos no están todavía aquí y
vamos a tener que aumentar los ahora el
18 ya tiene un 2 déjenme ponerlo con
otro color el 18 ya tiene un 2 porque
aquí está en este mínimo común múltiplo
el 3 también paga este de aquí también
paga porque ya hay un 3 aquí en este
mínimo común múltiplo tengo 12 tengo un
3 pero aquí me va hace falta otro 3 y
eso es muy importante como me hace falta
otro 3 entonces lo voy a poner aquí lo
voy a poner aquí para que se pueda
formar también el número 18 es decir que
el 18 es lo mismo que 2 x 3 x 3 que es
justo lo que tenemos aquí 2 x 3 x 3 esto
de aquí me da el número de 18 así que ya
puedo formar aquí el número 18 y el
número 24
que el mínimo común múltiplo de estos
dos wow ya llegué a la solución es dos
por dos por dos por tres estos 24 por 3
24 por 3 es lo mismo que vamos a hacerlo
aquí 24 lo voy a multiplicar por 3 para
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo 3 por
4 12 llevamos unam 3 por 2 6 y 1 772
entonces el mínimo común de estos dos es
72 y esta es mi respuesta y de hecho lo
podemos verificar si nosotros nos
tomamos todos los múltiplos de 24 y
todos los múltiplos de 18 así que tienes
unos múltiplos de 24 24 es bueno pues su
primer múltiplo es 24 su siguiente
múltiplos sería sumarle 24 más y 24 más
24 es lo mismo que 48 estudio donde sumó
24 más me va a dar a 2 y llevamos 172 72
y así me puedo seguir y seguir y seguir
ahora vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con
el 18 si yo me fijo en los múltiplos de
quienes son bueno puesto 18 después 18
por 2 es 36 36 si yo le sumó 18 me dan a
aquí es 4 y llevo 154 ok y si a esto le
sumó 18 me va a dar 2 y llevamos 16 7 72
y así me puedo seguir y seguir seguir
pero lo que quiero que te des cuenta es
que ya llegamos a 1 común entre estos
dos que es el 72 y como es el primero
que se aparece por lo tanto es el mínimo
común múltiplo entre estos dos y bueno
este fue el método de la fuerza bruta
así que ya tengo que 72 por aquí 72 por
acá vamos a ponerlo como solución de
este problema
pongamos aquí la solución el mínimo
común múltiplo entre 24 y 18 el 72 y
vamos a comprobar respuesta de lujo
estamos bien así que eso es todo por
este vídeo y nos vemos en el siguiente